Hello Freak bitches and aren't binary star systems really comments more than
half the stars you've seen the night sky or binary or multiple systems.
In fact,
the iconic image from Star Wars,
the original star wars movie before they numbered them,
I think what star wars for [inaudible] right when they were,
well,
yeah,
whatever,
whatever that that,
that,
that desert planet that Luke was on and he comes out after visiting his was what
is the step parent?
Know his adoptive parents wa I don't remember who he was visiting.
He comes out and you see a double sunset.
So that's basically the only accurate science and the entire series.
It's star wars series
thousand.
Nothing I really enjoyed is you're taking a part of gravity gravity and how many
people got mad movie?
Yeah,
you don't.
So I stopped coming.
Come movies.
I don't need to Piss people off.
I think when I watch a movie,
I'm having those thoughts anyway,
so I might as well share them with people if you're interested.
So I did just that.
And then people,
the last time I did it was for star wars.
The Force Awakens Star Wars seven.
I had a series of tweets,
you know,
one of them was um,
BB eight,
a smooth rolling metal spherical ball would have skidded uncontrollably on sand.
People got angry so much.
So what?
Tweeted back,
shut the fuck up.
Okay.
So,
so I said,
okay,
I'm not here to get people angry.
I'm just here to enlightened to help people enhance their movie going
experience.
But to the extent that is not accomplishing this,
I don't need to do it.
I'm just saying I don't,
I'm an educator.
I thought I was being nice.
I don't need to do.
So I haven't tweeted about a movie since then.
I got tweets,
I could post them,
stop.
I have tweets I could post about arrival
was a little bit of a shut it off.
Okay.
No,
you've got to give it a chance.
I,
as soon as I see a movie that starts out,
I don't spoil.
Alert starts out with a sick kid.
I'm like,
fuck you.
No,
no,
no.
You're doing no.
In fact,
it's very not about the kid.
I'm sure that's why I keep is totally not about the kid.
Chamie hated it.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
So you just give it a chance.
But anyhow,
so I just stopped.
Maybe I'll come back,
but I'm,
yeah,
and people need to know gravity.
That was good that you explained that not only is this not plausible,
those two satellites on anywhere near each other,
they're like,
God said,
oh,
there's the,
there's the international space station and I'm on the Chinese space station.
Let me just jet pack my way there.
Do you really,
excuse me lady.
Hey Lady.
Do you know how far away these are from one another?
You can just jet around from one space station to another.
No,
can't do it.
There are tens of thousands of miles from one another,
but goodness sakes.
So,
but anyhow,
so I,
yeah,
you remembered it was like 15 tweets and I didn't know that was when I realized
like the press was reading my movie tweets and those tweets.
There's now a couple of years ago when the gravity came out with Sandra Bullock
and,
and um,
uh,
what's the dude's name?
George Clooney.
So I tweeted it and they got talked about on the t on the today show,
set the set the weekend today show on NBC.
Then it was talked about on NBC nightly news.
Then my tweets were talking about on Saturday night lives,
the weekend update.
It was like the NBC Trifecta.
And I said,
my gosh,
this was,
I had not,
that was not the point.
I didn't seek this,
that fine.
I'm glad they are reacting this way because that means they care about the
science may be.
But what Seth Meyers it,
cause he was doing weekend update at the time.
He said,
uh,
astrophysicist Neil degrasse station harshly criticized the movie.
Granary uh,
saying has contains a number of scientific and accuracies,
for example.
There is no way George Clooney would have spent that much time talking to a
woman his own age.
That's hilarious.
I think Sandra Bullock's still younger than George Clooney though.
So they should have got their facts but not,
yeah,
but not by much.
I mean,
yeah,
they were the same neighborhood.
Yeah,
I think it's important.
I think you enjoy the movie.
It's great.
It's fun.
And everything like that.
But it's important to point out what the science errors are.
I think.
I think that the,
I think the movie could have done better,
honestly.
You know,
things they could have made the same movie I did collect.
Some people thought I didn't like the movie when all I was doing was pointing
out things they got wrong.
By the way,
they did some stunning things correctly.
For example,
this was,
this was brilliant.
If you're in zero g a fire basically puts itself out.
So think about when you burn a candle on earth.
Uh,
so you light the wick.
If there's people have candles anymore,
they'd forgot what a candle.
You light it with a match that you used to get from smoking lounges and bars.
All right,
so you light the candle and it stays lit.
The fuel is the wax.
The oxygen continually comes in because it heats the air around it in the air
rises,
hot air rises and fresh air comes in from below and has fresh oxygen.
So the candle stay lit until it burns all the way down in space.
If you light a candle,
you can light the candle.
It'll heat the air,
but the air will not know where to go because it's not lighter than everything
because it's in zero g it's a stake clustered around the candle.
The candle will use up all the oxygen in that bubble and that it'll put itself
out.
They did this in the movie,
so why did they have some good science?
Because they make,
you can't think of everything,
so they just have you on staff.
She couldn't think of anything if I,
so you can't think of everything.
So I wasn't judgemental so much as this movie.
The fact that it got so much right is what put it on my map to criticize what it
got wrong.
That makes sense at,
does that make that make sense?
Okay,
that's good to hear the word Yo.
All the hair,
her bangs should have been floating,
floating all over it.
Now if you might think,
am I the nit picky?
No,
because if you'll get any picture of somebody with hair,
okay,
in space in zero g there,
here is flying everywhere.
It was the first thing you notice about them.
It is so obvious like,
wow,
that's the cool,
you're not thinking about the space ship or the tie technology.
You look at it,
the hair doing stuff you will never see happen on earth unless someone is like
underwater and they're jiggling their head.
So they would have to film it all in zero gravity.
They would have to film it on when those drop things or the drop thing,
they'd have to be clever about it.
And she only had bangs.
That's all you have to figure out how to,
they did other clever things.
So anyway,
that's all I did play.
By the way.
In all fairness to movies,
I'll call out something that's good.
That science,
that movie got right that otherwise got no science.
Right.
I'll be,
I'm the first in line to do that.
Like what?
Oh,
uh,
in the movie monsters inc.
Oh my gosh.
You've in fact doing the thing.
I was going there.
And did you,
uh,
those doors were four dimensional portals to,
to another.
That's possible.
Well,
if you had four dimensions,
that's what it would look like.
Do you remember the movie?
Yes.
They take the doors home.
They opened the door and they're in the closet of the kid that they're going to
terrorize.
Yes.
That's a wormhole.
That's what that is.
What access to the fourth dimension looks like?
Do you think scientifically?
That's possible one day?
I hope so.
Cause here's the example.
W W we've got a nice broad desk.
We here at that,
at this interview,
right?
So desk is two dimensions.
It's got length and width and I can start putting papers on this desk and I can
lay them out mosaic style.
And then all of a sudden I have no more room to put a sheet of paper.
If I'm an aunt living in this surface of the desk,
I say,
no more room,
but wait a minute,
we are three dimensional people and I can put an organizer and and and stack
things vertically so I can take a sheet of paper and now I can put it higher up
than the surface of the desk.
The aunt will say,
we did it go,
oh my gosh,
it disappeared in some portal.
We're no,
no.
What?
What is that?
It went into the third dimension and the aunt bound and obviously as a three
dimensional thing,
right?
And imagine it only lives in two dimensions.
You would have made that paper disappear into a third dimension and it will have
no clue where it went because you had a portal,
you had access to the extra dimension.
So look at how much you can store on a desk when you have access to a third
dimension above it.
Vastly more than just papers mosaic out on the surface.
So now let's up this example by a dimension.
You're storing boxes in a room or I ran out of room.
No you didn't.
Let's open this four dimensional door.
You open it,
put the boxes through the door,
close the door,
boxes gone.
That'd be awesome.
For hoarders you,
you look around the other side of the bar,
the door,
there's nothing there,
right?
The your side of the door,
nothing there.
It's just a door that a portal to a fourth dimension that can hold vastly more
content.
Then what is what you're stuck storing in the three dimensional space of your
room.
Now that sounds so the,
that's a brilliant concept.
And even though it has monsters that don't exist that all speak English and is,
one of them is a cycle ops,
and one of them is,
uh,
you know,
I'm not judging the biophysiology of these creatures,
but they got the physics of a four dimensional portals completely accurate.
Now the concept of dimensions is where it gets really abstract with Pete,
I love me some dimensions,
and it is abstract.
It is.
No,
and that's why you,
you've take,
let the math take you into those higher dimensions because our intuition will
not,
will fail for us.
Yeah.